when you wake up in the morning it can't
just be about problems
it's okay that blank
sheet of paper stage is one of the
hardest stages and one of the reasons
it's hard is because
there's at that stage there's nobody
counting on you but yourself
i delivered papers i worked at pennies i
sold golf balls i had a pinball machine
round i did a lot of things
that enabled me to accumulate about ten
thousand dollars by the time i got out
of school
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside youtube
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe
life and learn the seven best lessons
from elon musk jeff bezos and other
billionaire entrepreneurs enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be excited about
life is it going to be a business kind
of tourism
in in orbit or is it uh
more kind of plan b if things on earth
do not develop as well
it's not exactly a plan b it's it's more
that i think i think there's two aspects
to this
one is that we want to have a future
that is inspiring
and exciting and what are the things
that you find
inspiring and exciting about the future
i think
one a future where we are a space-faring
civilization and out there among the
stars
i think that's every kid gets excited
about that you don't even need to teach
them
they just get it's like instinctive and
so we it's very important for us to have
reasons to
like reasons to be excited about life
like when you wake up in the morning it
can't just be about problems
it's okay i know everyone in this room
deals with a lot of tough problems
but you know it's got to be more than
that so
you know i think a future where you can
say hey even if it's not you
there's gonna be people out there
they're gonna we can have a base on the
moon
we're gonna have a you know a city on
mars maybe
go further moons of jupiter and
everything i think that's a very
exciting future
rule number two listen to life's
whispers with oprah winfrey
in all of the years of doing the oprah
show
there were many days that i sat in my
chair across from
one or two or five or six or seven
people and i would be
so frustrated because
i just wanted to shake people sometimes
and say why didn't you pay attention
to your life i said on the show probably
the producers tell me that they counted
33 times but i know i thought it
at least a thousand times i would say
listening to your life
as it whispers to you first so that it
does not have to knock you upside the
head
with a brick or come crashing down on
you
as a brick wall is one of the greatest
principles of life because there are
many things that happen
in life that are beyond our control
natural disasters death
unexplained events but there are also
many many many things in life which we
can control
and become out of control because you're
just
not paying attention you are
sleepwalking through your life
and i have seen this so many times on
the show
i wanted to take the guests and go would
you just pay
attention so this is what i've learned
and how
i've explained it to myself
life whispers to you all the time
your life is speaking to you all around
from the time you wake up in the morning
and every single experience that's
coming into
your personal space into your
physical space all of those experiences
are speaking to you they're telling you
something
about your life and about your
circumstances
it whispers and if you don't get the
whisper
the whisper gets louder if you don't get
the whisper when it gets louder
it gets i call it like a little pebble
like a little thump upside your head
when i was a kid if i was doing
something my grandmother didn't like
she'd just turn around and thump me she
wouldn't even look at me she'd just give
me a thump
and i know that's that's my cue to stop
it
or you we're going to get worse the
whisper is the message the pebble or the
thump upside
the head usually it's gone into a
problem
you don't pay attention to the problem
the problem becomes a brick
upside your head the brick upside your
head is a crisis
you don't pay attention to the brick
upside your head the crisis turns into a
disaster
and the whole house brick wall comes
falling down
rule number three start simple with jeff
bezos
that blank sheet of paper stage is one
of the hardest stages and one of the
reasons it's hard is because
there's at that stage there's nobody
counting on you but yourself
you know one of the things that is very
motivating today it's easy because we've
got
you know millions of customers counting
on us and
you know thousands of investors counting
on us and then thousands of employees
all counting on each other but in that
beginning stage
it's really just you and you can quit
anytime nobody's going to care
and so you set about doing the simple
things first so
you want to start a company well the
first thing you do is you should write a
business plan
and so i did that i wrote about a
30-page business plan i wrote a first
draft in fact i wrote the first draft on
the car trip
uh from you know from from the east
coast to the west coast
and that was uh
that is very helpful you know the
business plan won't survive
its first encounters with reality um it
will always be different
the reality will never be the plan but
the the discipline of writing the plan
forces you to think
through some of the issues and to get
sort of mentally comfortable
in the space lesson number four get
known
with grant cardone it does not matter
who you know it matters who knows you
so i'm going to go up i'm going to go
i'm trying to get to feed you right
okay look i mean i could know some i
could know some people that own places
in fiji
but what if it's already booked they
can't kick them out
but what if people in fiji knew i was
coming
they're like hey mr cardone i want them
calling me i don't want to call them
and so who knows you we're back to the
question of who's got my money who's got
your money is who knows you
people do business with people they know
it's how business has been done for two
thousand years in this plan
not people don't do business with people
they trust they do but they first do
business
with people they know i got to know you
before i trust you
and i would rather do business with
somebody i know
and don't trust i do business with
people every day i don't trust
every day i have to don't you think
there's there's an element of
so for example but i know i want to get
this deal i know they can get the deal
done with me
right like the real estate broker i know
i'm not
getting quite the truth from him on this
or that but you know what he's got the
deal
i just did two deals i did 120 million
by the real estate deals with the same
guy
i don't really like him right but i'm
doing business with him
and and this is not a new thing for
anybody anybody that's not doing
business with people they don't want to
do business with is lying
there's somebody you got people that
work for you you don't like
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five get ahead of the game with
warren buffett
it is always being ahead of the game
rather than getting behind the game it's
saving a little no matter how you do it
i mean i
delivered papers i worked at pennies i
sold golf balls i had a pinball machine
round i did a lot of things
that enabled me to accumulate about ten
thousand dollars by the time i got out
of school
uh ten thousand doesn't go as far now as
it did then but it
having anything so that you're ahead of
the game and not getting behind the game
is enormously important i mean just you
know if you're going to run 100
100 yard dash against a bunch of people
in life
if you can figure it out so that when
the gun goes off you're 10 or 15 yards
ahead
instead of 10 or 15 yards behind it's
going to make an enormous difference in
how that race comes out so
having having some net resources
doesn't make much difference whether
they're in stocks or bonds in my view
but
and not having debt when that gun goes
off when you get out of school
uh is a huge plus over being behind the
game and
uh you know it may come from delivering
a paper out in the morning it may come
from part-time work someplace but
but put aside a few dollars for yourself
but uh
so that when the time comes and you
enter
you enter the workforce uh you're ahead
of the game and not behind and then once
you get there don't get behind by buying
a whole lot of things that
you figure you're going to pay for some
day while you're paying 20 interest in
between
rule number six have a vision with jack
ma are there any leadership principles
um you know that that have contributed
to your success as a leader
not as an entrepreneur leader does never
fix the style right
some leaders good speaking some leader
never speak by actions
leader leadership doesn't have a style
everybody can be a leader a good leader
should have a vision the vision
is that vision not necessarily good
because when i work in the company
when everybody was disappointed i have
to tell them
i have to see before the other people
see the opportunity
where everybody excited i have to see
the disaster
especially as a ceo of like a me and
alibaba group
my job is to see the problems
of the future so
and kill the problems before the
disaster comes
so a leader must have a vision and rule
number seven the last one before a very
special bonus clip
is work with extraordinary people with
peter thiel
so let's say you're trying to select
people for your teal fellowships
or maybe to work for one of your
companies or to start a new company with
and just you peter thiel as a judge of
talent
what trait do you look for in that
person that is being undervalued by
others
a lot of what you're looking for are
like these almost zen-like
opposites so you want people who are
both really stubborn
and really open-minded okay that's like
like a little bit contradictory
um you want um you want people who are
um you know sort of idiosyncratic and
really different
but then who can work well together in
teams um
and so this is again sort of maybe not
180 degrees opposite that's
like 175 degrees and this is why you
like kegel
not not i don't like hagel that much but
um
but but um but so but so i think it's um
so if you sort of focus
too much on one or the other end of it
you'd get it completely uh
you would tend to get it completely
wrong so uh so i i
but i i like to get things where you get
these combinations of unusual traits so
uh so if you have people with some you
know really interesting
very different idea okay that suggests
okay we're sort of in the
idiosyncratic category then the
important question becomes
okay would they actually be able to
function socially and execute and then
then maybe the teamwork question you'd
ask would be what's the prehistory of
this company how did you meet how long
have you been working together
and if there's a long prehistory that
would be that would be good on the other
side so i think it's always getting
these combinations right
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the science says that when you just
watch a video
you get motivated to get inspired you
have a 35 chance
of following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here
you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through
when you write it down you have a 91
chance of following through
and when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95
chance from 30 something percent to 95
chance of you following through believe
nation we need to make this happen
so question of the day your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action specific for the
next week
put it down in the comments below and
i'm going to show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
everyone thinks that spanx actually
started when i cut the feet out of my
pantyhose but the truth is it started
many many years before that
it started when i was selling fax
machines door-to-door
getting kicked out of office buildings
day in and day out
and i woke up one morning and i thought
i'm in the wrong movie
how did this happen this is not my life
cut scene call the director call the
producer
no and i took out a piece of paper and i
wrote down what i was good at
and there was not much on the page the
word
i saw the word sales i knew i was good
in sales so i wrote down
in my journal i want to invent a product
that i can sell to millions of people
that will make them feel good
and then i asked the universe for an
idea
and i waited for two years and the idea
showed up and the minute i cut the feet
out of my pantyhose i decided to pursue
it
so what do you do when you have an idea
and you've never
taken a business class or worked in
fashion or retail
i wanted to patent my idea and
i ended up looking for a female patent
attorney
and i called the georgia chamber of
commerce
and they said there actually wasn't a
single female patent attorney in the
entire state of georgia
so i looked in the yellow pages and
found three men's name and
went out and pitched my idea to them and
they actually thought the idea was so
bad that one of the patent lawyers later
admitted to me he thought i'd been sent
by candid camera
which makes sense because he was looking
around the room for the hidden cameras
but
he ended up eventually helping me i went
to barnes noble bought a book on patents
and trademarks wrote my own patent
and went back to him and said please
please will you just write the claims
portion of it
and he did for a discounted price but it
makes me think about inventors and
innovators and when you hear those words
do you think of women
last year my son had inventor
week at his school and they asked me to
come and be the keynote speaker
at his kindergarten class
so i was the inventor that was coming
and i started out looking at all these
cute little kids and i said
so what does an inventor look like and
all their hands shot up and one kid said
it's a man and he has crazy hair and
somebody else raised her in and said no
no it's a bald man
no it's a tall man it's a short man and
i just stopped and i said
well i'm an inventor and their eyes got
really big and they said you
are and it dawned on me i looked around
the room and all the
pictures of inventors were albert
einstein thomas edison steve jobs so
i can see why the the young girl who
asked me and said i didn't know girls
could be inventors was surprised
and even my son on the way home he goes
mom you're an inventor
but the real point of all of this was i
wanted to help women and i'm so
passionate about it
and it's amazing that i started with
their butts and i've continued to groan
i
started at the sarah blakely foundation
because i truly believe
that the world would be a much better
place if the male and female energy on
the planet was more balanced
how would you describe each phase of the
evolution of oracle
and how would you uh sort of describe
running each of those phases you got to
do this quick
i gotta well i mean and clearly being a
part of a company with four people and
being a
part of a company and by the way that's
we're 85 000 now post
post merger with sun you know on 100 uh
we think of it
son's got about 20 000 employees and you
know uh twenty five thousand employees
we're about a hundred five thousand
uh so uh hundred five hundred ten
thousand we're not sure exactly
about that uh i mean clearly my job is
constantly changed uh
what has not changed is i ran
engineering at oracle on the first day
i run engineering today the one part of
the company i have always paid attention
to
and is always reported directly to me is
engineering not sales
not marketing not support and not
consulting not services
at various points in time lots of other
people have run run those operations the
back office
accounting order management all of these
things the only thing
that i've done consistently during those
32 years is run engineering
because i believe basically that once
you reach
you will you know you'll win as as we
say at oracle
it's amazing our good products seem to
do very well and our bad products
not so well so the thing i focused on
and i think we get the most
most leverage is developing the right
products recruiting the right engineers
and having the right organization
so mr buffett in the past you invested
in china south korea and israel
and recently you partnered with 3g
capital and joshua lemon
um from brazil over for the heinz deal
uh does this mean are you tempted to
venture into the brazil market next
i didn't get the question question you
did the heinz deal
the question is are you going to invest
in brazil next oh uh
i don't know where i'm going to invest
next that's what that's what makes my
job interesting i mean
i'm i'm i'm not kidding i mean if you
went out
and played golf and every drive went in
the hole
you'd give up the game wouldn't be
interesting i mean what what's
interesting is when you get in the rough
and you have to come out and a few
things like that so
i i love the fact that i don't know what
i'm going to do next you mentioned the
israel investment
in 2006 in the fall
i got a letter from a fellow and i never
heard of him
and i never heard of the company he was
talking about but he said my name is
eton wardheimer
and i want to tell you a little about my
company ishkar the letter was a page
and a half long and he said if he sold
the company
the family sold the company the only
company they wanted to sell it to was
berkshire hathaway
and if i was interested they'd be glad
to come over from israel and explain it
to me and it was a
it just jumped off the page that this
was an interesting idea so i
emailed them and they came over very
shortly and and we bought the business
we we handed them
four billion dollars for 80 of a company
where i'd never seen it or anything
eitan kept saying you got to come over
to israel and see the plants and
everything you won't believe how
wonderful they are and i said eitan
i don't go to council bluffs iowa you
know i mean
i am doing fine in omaha and uh
he said no you know you got to see it i
said no no i don't i i said
we can make a deal without seeing it he
said well if you buy if you buy the
company will you come and see it
i said if we buy the company i'll come
so we bought the company
and i went over there and it's true i've
never seen plants like this it was the
greatest operation i've ever
seen and etan said to me he said you
know that's why i want you to come over
to see these things i said listen
if i'd come and see them i'd pay more
money so
so it we
we have a wonderful partnership with the
people in israel but i don't know
tomorrow
uh our partnership with the people in
brazil with george apollo lemon and his
associates
they are sensational people uh i got to
know george apollo when i was on the
port of gillette with him
and the opportunity to buy into a
wonderful business
like heinz and to be partners and they
do
they'll do all the heavy lifting they
run the place uh with george apollo and
associates i mean it's just it's a it's
a great opportunity
for us and i don't know what the
opportunity will be tomorrow with george
apollo is last december
uh i was going out to boulder colorado
where he had a group that met
and he said i think i've got an idea
might interest you when i get out there
so i went out there and
and as we came back on the plane he
explained what he was thinking about in
terms of heinz and i said
count me in and uh and i'll tell you one
other thing which is
quite impressive about him after i said
that and went a little
look further on the thing he sent me a
one-page
governance description of how it would
work between the two of us and he sent
me a very brief description of
what he thought would be a fair deal for
both of us i didn't have to change a
word
during my california springs and summers
i spent most of my days in the high
sierras in yosemite valley
working as a river guide and a rock
climbing instructor
i loved those jobs but unfortunately
they didn't pay that well
so i also got a job working a couple of
days a week as a computer programmer
back in berkeley i learned a program in
college
i didn't love programming but it was fun
and i was good at it and computer pro
programming gave me the same kind of
satisfaction
as solving math problems and playing
chess
both things i enjoyed before before i
became a confused teenager
at this point in my life i thought i was
making
real progress on my journey of
self-discovery
i had found a cause i had a couple of
jobs that i love
and one that was fun and paid the bills
i was pretty happy with my life
my wife was not
what she saw was a college dropout who
spent too much time in the mountains
doing
foolish things she wanted me to work
full time as a computer programmer
or go back to college and finish my
degree
we compromised sort of
i started taking classes at uc berkeley
i took several classes but the only one
i can remember
was a sailing class taught at berkeley
marina
once again i fell in love and began a
lifelong affair
with the limitless omnipotent pacific
ocean
when my class was over i wanted to buy a
sailboat
my wife said this was the single
stupidest idea
she had ever heard in her entire life
she accused me of being irresponsible
and she told me i lacked ambition
kicked me out and then she divorced me
[Music]
this was a pivotal moment in my life
[Applause]
my family was still mad at me for not
going to medical school
and now my wife was divorcing me because
i lacked ambition
it looked like a reoccurrence of the
same old problem
once again i was unable to live up to
the expectations of others
but this time i was not disappointed in
myself
for failing to be the person they
thought i should be
their dreams and my dreams were
different
i would never confuse the two of them
again i know you all understand better
than most
that real progress requires authentic
an authentic way of being honesty and
above all
empathy i have to say that the single
most
important lesson i learned in 25 years
talking
every single day to people was that
there is a common denominator in
our human experience most of us
i tell you we don't want to be divided
what we want the common denominator that
i found in every single interview
is we want to be validated we want to be
understood i've done over 35
000 interviews in my career
and as soon as that camera shuts off
everyone always turns to be and
inevitably in their own way
asks this question was that okay
i heard it from president bush i heard
it from president obama
i've heard it from heroes and from
housewives i've heard it from
victims and perpetrators of crimes i
even heard it from beyonce and all of
her beyonce
she finishes performing hands me the
microphone and says was that okay
friends and family yours enemies
strangers in every argument
in every encounter every exchange i will
tell you
they all want to know one thing
was that okay did you hear me
do you see me did what i say
mean anything to you and even though
this is the college
where facebook was born
my hope is that you will try to go out
and have more face-to-face conversations
with people
you may disagree with
that you'll have the the
courage to look them in the eye and hear
their point of view
and help make sure that the speed and
distance
and anonymity of our world doesn't cause
us to lose
our ability to stand in somebody else's
shoes
and recognize all that we share as a
people
this is imperative for you as an
individual and
for our success as a nation if i sit
with a hundred dollars in my pocket
folks
there is no economy if you want to be
economic
you let money flow it has to move you
got people in your company managers and
executives that are saving money
they save their money i'm like what are
you doing dude we're saving money how
can you grow a department
if you go home and all you do is save it
you know you open up somebody's freezer
and they got ice cream
that's three months old it's got this
much left
in you you got you got diet coke
that's four days old it's got that much
left in it okay
you got ziploc containers you have whole
cabinets of
ziploc containers and little plastic
things where you
in case you had some leftover corn or
peas
or potatoes you're like don't throw it
away
save that save that that much
pork chop maybe i'll hit it tomorrow
see like there's somebody put this back
in here that's probably elena doing that
there's no reason to put this back here
reminds me of my mama
reminds me of when i grew up save
everything
it's a terrible product anyway why you
want to save it look at this
she put two apples in here don't put
them back in the refrigerator man
[Music]
eat them or toss them you're not gonna
go broke
or get rich saving leftovers
what are you guys doing man you got it
in your closet that you ain't ever gonna
wear
it don't fit you it ain't fit you in in
years
right how many of you got stuff at your
house you could get rid of
you're trying to save stuff dude how can
you
how can you have new stuff come in when
you're holding on
to stuff that you don't even use
right so you have to use this it only
becomes valuable
when it's used now the question is what
are you going to use it on
and the other question is why don't you
use it
why are you so compelled to hold on to
it
what do y'all think that is you know how
to get more number one reason i don't
your mother did not know how to get a
new shirt
that's why she took so much put so much
time and energy
in cleaning the shirt you got a stain on
okay you broke a toy your parents got
upset with you
can't believe you did that what did what
man dude
toys are to be broken that's what a good
toy is for
right right i lost a quarter when i was
eight years old and i would have thought
i would have thought my house was going
to get torn apart because my dad became
so upset about the quarter
you're playing with money never play
with money what are you doing playing
with money and that that that lesson
pounded on me so hard it kept me from
making real money for 20 years
you know people often ask me what it
takes to start a business
what is the key ingredient how do i how
do i start the business and
how do we grow to about 20 million
dollar 20 million dollars in sales so
quickly
you know they all come up with some new
whiz-bang idea they're going to invent
the the better mouse trap they're going
to come up with new software new
hardware
and more often than not it seems like
they've spent their millions before they
they thought through their idea but when
we talk about new companies and and
growth and success
there really is only one common
ingredient
across any type of business whether it's
oil or computers or soft or anything and
that key ingredient
is customers without customers
whether you're starting a business
running a business
expanding a business you don't have a
business
there is no business customers are the
key ingredient get those profits
you got to have the customers you got to
have happy customers
that's the bottom line you know micro
solutions we've been we've been going
and growing
and it's impossible not to have growing
pains it's impossible not to make
mistakes
we screw up all the time and you know it
doesn't bother me as president
if i ever if i have an employee who just
didn't do something right
just made a mistake it's good
because if you're not making mistakes
you're not trying hard enough you know
these things i'm saying they're not
unique they're not things that i just
thought up in some
some miracle growth you know things when
i talk to people in our company when i
talk to people about
our company i never have a unique
thought i can't remember i don't know
that i ever did i can't remember if i
ever will or don't expect ever to
there's no magic formulas to customer
service there's no magic formulas to
doing things right
these these sayings that you hear me say
are things that i've read elsewhere and
just regurgitate back but how many
people do
them you know we all know the golden
rule
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you and that's nice
you know but do you do it but even more
importantly than the golden rule what
about the lovers rule
do one to others as you would love to
have them do unto you
that's what we try to stress the micro
solution that's what we try to use to
differentiate ourselves
not just to get by because everybody's
going to be nice
you know when you invite someone into
your house that is an acquaintance that
you like okay
you're going to offer them coffee you're
going to offer them a doughnut
and that's really what you expect you
know if you went to their house because
you're just acquaintances but when you
leave the house
it was nice if you go that's fine if you
don't go back fine
that's the way customers look at
businesses if i go back fine if i don't
go back fine
you know they say that 80 of the people
who have a problem tell at least 10
people
only ten percent of the people who had a
good experience tell anybody
and it's the same way when you go to
visit an acquaintance
and when people come to try to do
business with micro solutions i hope
i pray and i try to convey to each and
every one of our people
that we give them a reason to want to
come back
we give them a reason to do a good
morning wrap to say okay let's do
business with micro solutions
you've got to really concentrate to do
unto others as you would love to have
them do unto you
even after you had done your thing there
was still an
eighth course to make sure that yahoo
itself was on track do you know what
that was about
yeah they were screwing everything up
you know i mean look they had they had
an opportunity to
dominate um streaming media they also
owned
at the same time the patent to cost per
click
yeah right now google's entire business
to this day
is built around pay-per-click rather
they're not calling pay-per-click yeah
so they had the entire patent for
pay-per-click
had they just said sorry google you
can't use it
there would be no google instead they
said yeah
133 million dollars and give us some
stock
they were just too nice right which
blinded them in a lot of respects and
i remember walking in with a 32 million
dollar sale
saying okay we're going to do streaming
we're going to sell all this company's
content
you know it's worth 32 million dollars
for us and it's going to pre-up
these other potential competitors and
um i forget if it's jerry or tim whoever
said no
we don't work that way we don't preempt
competition we just leave it open
i'm like okay it's time for me to go buy
a basketball team
that's they just they just didn't see
these things and i mean it's a lesson in
your businesses there's going to be
everybody's always trying to kick your
ass and you have to figure out how to
kick your out your own ass first
seriously because if you're not brutally
honest with yourself and your own
business
about what your frailties are someone
else is going to find them
yahoo didn't get that yahoo just thought
you know what we're just going to
continue moving forward and we'll just
compete with everybody else
and you know there's we have no other
problems one time
you know as you know i went to indiana
and
in dallas in the mid 90s you know when
we had a good basketball team
we literally would when we wanted to
listen to our big games like indiana
purdue
go hoosiers um we would call somebody in
bloomington who would put a radio next
to a speaker phone
and dial us and we sit on the other side
listening over a speakerphone drinking
our beer and whipping it up or doing
whatever
and the internet was just starting to
happen and now i'm a tech geek and i'm
like into all of it
and we're like there's got to be a
better way to do this and so
one of my buddies from indiana todd
wagner was like look
we've been thinking about this and i'm
like no i'll figure it out i'm a
networking guy now
and so we looked for ways to
um stream indiana basketball we called
it net casting back then
over the brand new internet and so i
went out and bought a packard bell
90 megahertz computer and an isdn line
and downloaded all the software and i
said you know what i'm going to figure
it out
and lo and behold by oh
golly early 1995 we had figured out a
way
to we would we took
these eight hour vcrs and connected it
to a local radio station
record them we'd bring them back go
through this process called encoding
and put it up on this website we call it
audionet
and then i'd go to any online forum aol
prodigy compuserve uunet whatever it was
or you use use
use that and i like if you're interested
in dallas sports
at all because we hadn't gotten to
indiana yet if you're interested in
dallas sports
go to this website audionet and back
then
you had a dial up modem you had to
download the software called tcpip
and you had to have software from your
internet provider
which meant that so few people knew how
to use it we had no idea if it would
work or not
but all of a sudden audionet went from
10 people a day
to hundred people to a thousand people a
day and as we added radio stations
they're getting calls from all over the
world from people
who are listening to their shows on
demand not even lined
and then we worked with a company that
put together live software company
called zing and we made it live
and then everything changed and that's
really when streaming was born
and we just grew that and then in 1998
we got into video changed a name to
broadcast.com
went public and it was the biggest ipo
in the history of the stock market at
the time
um and then we sold it to yahoo wherever
you're at in life right now at this very
moment
i believe everyone has a knowing inside
of them
i don't think it matters if they have a
faith or no faith i don't think about
any of that i think everyone universally
has a knowing or a truth inside
uh and i think most people never learn
how to get still and hear it
and most people if they do get still and
hear it they're gonna know right now
live while they're listening to you and
me
are they in the right job they're
supposed to be in
or is there is are they are they playing
it small
are they in the right relationship or
are they in it and dimming their own
light because of fear
that maybe they'll be alone we all have
a knowing right
and you know what i'll say about the
idea of
giving up leveling up all of that i
think it's so important that
um you know in that moment where i had
the and again let me just say there's so
much i did wrong and i share all that
stuff too
one of the things i did right was when i
had this this
gut feeling as i'm sitting there with
this skin problem
this gut feeling oh you're supposed to
figure out how to
how to create a beauty company when i
look back at this journey of
three years of constant rejection down
to under a thousand dollars in a bank
account
literally getting knocked down over and
over from all of these
beauty retailers that i put on a
pedestal and i couldn't understand why
they were telling me i wasn't the right
fit for them
every time i would check in with my gut
right and maybe so many people out there
can relate to this because you
you feel like you're doing something
you're supposed to be doing but like for
me there was no proof around me that my
idea was right
there was no traction in my business
there was nobody saying
yeah that's a great idea let me buy your
product and then i'm going to the beauty
retailers and they didn't believe
in the brand and everything around me
was saying you're wrong
and the easiest thing in life is to
confuse that with the truth and
my question to you is if you suddenly
found yourself to be uh say a sophomore
in college
at harvard what do you think you would
study and how do you think you'd
spend your time engaging activities
well the thing that you're likely to be
world class at
is whatever you obsessed over from say
age 12
to 18. you know in my case it was
writing software
uh where i would think i was good and
then i would meet somebody who would
tell me i wasn't and
i would look at their code and i went
through four sort of comeuppances
of oh that's what a really good
programmer looks like and part of the
reason i worship digital equipment was
eventually it was a couple of their very
best programmers
who came and shared with me how they
thought about it how they did thing and
i had studied their code and
uh and that and there were several
people who were
so key to my doing that so today
i would go into you know software which
today that means going into artificial
intelligence
uh you know computers still can't read
they they cannot take a book of
information
and say pass an ap test on that book
and that's a solvable problem but it's a
knowledge representation problem
and you know i've always wanted to solve
that problem uh i'm jealous
that maybe one of you gets to work on
that
i'm you know unlikely to go back and be
hands on in that
in that way but it's the juiciest
problem ever i've thought about it for a
long time
uh so i would go into ai yeah if you
want to have impact
uh usually delegation's important
although you know individual
contributors in terms of inventing a
drug or a new approach to things
that's phenomenal so when microsoft
first got started
i wrote most the code and everybody
else's code i read and kind of rewrote
uh and that got us up to 10 people
and then i had to say to myself okay
we're gonna ship code that i didn't edit
uh and that was hard for me uh but
you know i kind of got over that then i
still said okay i'm gonna interview
everyone
and i'm going to at least look at
samples of their code well that got us
up to about 40 people
and that was at a point where i had sold
way more software than we could write
because everybody was so
impressed and i thought well i need
to keep enough collect enough money to
you know keep hiring all these people
but uh
the demand was so high that you know we
were actually falling behind that's when
i hired steve
and steve figured out a uh
how to control what promises i made to
people uh and b
how to hire lots of people and good
really good people and create
organizations and teams so i delegated
to steve that
and he was constantly saying to me okay
we're gonna hire programmers that you've
never met and i'd say no or not and then
he would show me numerically that the
constraint wasn't gonna work
uh you know so uh then i said okay
then i would you know know all the
managers of the people and so over time
uh and of course you know i could say
the quality per person was falling
monotonically
according to me uh but you know large
problems uh if you want to you know
write the most popular
office productivity software that one
person
absolutely can't do that you can write
pretty code so
everyone has to decide what scale of
organization they want to
work in eventually you know my role was
very much as a leader
and a reviewer of managers but the top
people and i hired some super
experienced people
uh i would make sure they were pursuing
a common vision and they were well
coordinated
but in terms of a lot of management
stuff
they were way better than i was now i
had to have the framework
to know what mix of skills that we
needed and
you know when they were working well
enough together but a lot of
uh you know my value-added was picking
say to do graphics user interface or to
do an integrated office
uh type thing or to go global and not
use agents to have microsoft be present
all over the world
and so yeah picking what you're good at
and how you find the other people
uh to fill in those things that's super
important and most founders don't
aren't able to scale that up and kind of
give up the hands-on things that they
used to get a lot of
uh pleasure and comfort from so anyway
we
we got this company just about ready to
launch
and uh we're looking at it when looking
at this little tiny
fulfillment center we were here by then
in this building
we had a basement fulfillment center to
call it a fulfillment center was very
grand there's a lot of puffery
it was 400 square feet which is about
the size of a one car garage
and we launched this uh business and
we're looking at it and we didn't know
if anybody would order from us we really
didn't
and in fact one of the software
engineers looked at this little space
and he said i can't figure out whether
this is
incredibly optimistic or hopelessly
pathetic
um and indeed we didn't know we had no
idea whether anybody would want to buy
things in this way the business plan
called for uh generating sales very
slowly as customers change their
attitudes the original business plan
which i thought was very optimistic at
the time
called for amazon.com to generate 70
million dollars in sales in the year
2001.
we actually generated in excess of three
billion dollars in sales in the year
2001
and we knew by the way that we were
really on to something in those first 30
days
in the first 30 days we got
orders from all 50 states and 45
different countries
with not a dollar of advertising just
all word of mouth in the first year we
didn't spend anything on advertising
all of it was word of mouth and that
really forged the company as a
that we were going to focus on customer
experience we saw the power of word of
mouth so
so very very clearly in those early days
there's something great about
word of mouth online by the way and
feedback from customers which is that
email turns off the politeness gene in
the human being
it's wonderful so people actually tell
you what they really think
usually in all caps
and uh so we get lots of uh info and
feedback from our customers
and we try to try to use it well there's
a friend of mine who's got a great
saying about
creating a company um which is uh
creating trying to build a company and
have it succeed is like eating glass and
staring into the abyss
so i mean what tends to happen is it's
sort of quite exciting for the first
several months of starting a company and
then
then reality sets in things don't go as
well as planned
customers aren't signing up the
technology or the product isn't working
as well as you thought
and i think that can sometimes be
compounded by a recession
and it can be very very painful for
several years
so i think frankly starting a company
i would advise people to have a high
pain tolerance one of the first times
that i re
that i demoed recommendations live
with a live uh website i
was speaking to a group of wall street
analysts
and um and my number one recommendation
number one personal recommendation was
the dvd
called slave girls beyond infinity
and which was this is much less
embarrassing and you never know what
you're gonna get i never know exactly
what i'm gonna get because it is live
and
it does change you know from minute to
minute but i'm glad to see that today
i've gotten
you know apollo
uh and then i can see of course why was
i recommended this
because i bought cosmos and angle of
attack
and another book called apollo um so
uh but slave girls beyond infinity i'll
just show you was
was a little embarrassing
um what happened to that laser pointer
thing oh here it is
do not look directly into me okay um
and there it is slave girls from beyond
infinity
let's go over here uh this is pretty
interesting
it's so you can buy this dvd with a salt
of the killer bimbos
buy together it's only 1996.
all of that product clustering is done
automatically of course it
the um you come down and you'll notice
that you know customers who bought
slave girls also bought
sorority babes in the slime ball bolo
rama
and my personal favorite cannibal women
in the avocado jungle of death
and there's this interesting thing here
we um we even
know when things are part of a series so
we say and also they bought dvds from
the barbarian queen
series so we can click through a quick
click through and look at the barbarian
queen and
um there's a customer review here
uh it says for elena clarkson fans only
this is barbarian queen
two this is not even barbarian queen
it's
an incredibly bad film whose only
redeeming feature is lena clarkson in
and out of some skimpy outfits she's
completely gorgeous but even
she can't save a disaster of a film yeah
we faced a lot of challenges
but i'm sure alibaba is going to face
more challenges
we worry every day when i was young
when company was young we thought well
what if when alibaba
become that big my life would be easier
then now the companies that the bigger
the company the more problems i have
so why you are still small company
enjoy it you will never experience
the happiness of operating a small
company
any life we ain't going to be too big
you have so much headaches
so many things happening and people say
jack you know there are a lot of books
about you
but there's none of the books i write
myself if there's one book i want to
write
in the future it's called alibaba 1001
mistakes
we made so many mistakes
we had so many troubles believing or not
china build up e-commerce company
build up internet related company
no internet connection at that time
no fee no no credit cards
no delivery system it's
so we make we meet problems all the time
it's not easy but we tell ourselves
we will be successful until we make 10
000 mistakes
we will be successful if we survive
in any crisis so when crisis came
we know it's a challenge everybody
start to be united we solve the
challenge
then we complete each other before
we solve the problem of the crisis we
should not complain
so i have a problem in
in hr i have a problem in financing i
have a problem with technology i have a
problem everywhere tell me so that's why
i i become a mentor in
entrepreneurs uh program in china
people a lot of entrepreneurs have
crashing when i listen to their
questions
oh my god i have this problem too so
i would say we have gone through almond
almost nine more than 90 percent of the
problems
that any entrepreneur 90 of the problems
that any entrepreneurs have met this is
what we feel proud
at the end of the day i'm going to tell
my kids my grandchildren
it's not the thing we feel proud we
we made alibaba it's so many mistakes
that we overcome so many challenges
we experience that make me feel proud
life is about experience
so when you become entrepreneur don't
worry about the competitors
don't worry about the mistakes don't
worry about the challenges
go through it that's the great fun part
of your business of your experience and
then
you got a courage you got a wisdom you
got a team follow you do you remember
how much your first server cost you said
oh yeah no
85 dollars 85.00 yeah no and i remember
that because um that was the gating
factor for us launching new schools i
i mean we had this philosophy from the
very beginning that we didn't want to be
this project it wasn't even a company at
the very beginning but we didn't want to
be burning a lot of money right we
weren't planning on raising a lot of
money we didn't want to be
one of these things that raised a bunch
of money and you know was losing a bunch
of money and then decided that we'd
somehow pull it through at the end and
um so you know so 85
for the first server put ads on the site
and the the ads at the beginning were
uh we just were running some kind of ad
network and do you remember what the
first ad was
um no i don't um
i don't know how did you get ads um this
was eduardo's job
was i mean with your ad sales yeah he
basically like he was responsible for
making sure that we had enough money to
keep things running in the beginning
and um you know but basically i mean so
it was the server was 85
and you know dustin and i basically
worked on kind of efficiency and making
sure that we can fit more schools onto
each server
um and um and eduardo worked on selling
more ads or making a deal so that we can
get
an ad network so that way we can we can
make more money but then whenever we had
more money we
rented another 85 a month server and we
kind of went from there
and um i don't know just it's just an
interesting way of seeing you never
spent money you didn't have in the
beginning
not in the beginning no and then i mean
even that was the constraint on your
growth rate how many new 85 dollars is
you could get
yeah and i mean it was actually good
because i i mean you know sometimes it's
really nice to have the time to
get your product to be awesome and deal
with scaling problems and one of the
things that was interesting
was um you know at the time i don't know
how many people remember this but i mean
friendster was the service that had
massive scaling problems yeah you know
the idea was they were they grew quickly
and it was really hard for them to scale
and
um you know the fact that we could kind
of go college by college and
and kind of optimize the service and
make it more efficient and offer new
features but make sure that they worked
i think was really key i mean we're
talking about people who've never built
a company before we never built any
large-scale software
or anything so having that period where
we could just bake it
and you know people these days like to
talk about how these services grow super
quickly
then facebook did grow quickly but i
think it took a year for us to get a
million users and we thought that that
was incredibly fast but
um and and i think it is but it wasn't
as quick as a lot of things grow today
and i think actually having that time
to bake it was really valuable process
of me cutting the feet out of my
pantyhose
while trying to get the prototype made
before i launched it was two years so
there was a year
solid of me driving in north carolina on
the weekends and
at night or taking time off from work to
go
and work on the prototype get it made i
learned so many things that i didn't
know
as a consumer it had never dawned on me
you know that men were making all of our
undergarments
so i learned very quickly that the
industry had been taking an average
waistband size between
a small and an extra large and putting
the same waistband on every pair
exactly that's what i said i said you
know
that's not working we're really
uncomfortable
and they were doing it to cut cost and
production so i
immediately changed that in a spanx
waistband a size small gets a small
medium gets a medium and so on
makes perfect sense right
i also realized that they had been
putting a tiny rubber cord
inside the waistbands that had been
there forever well we had made so many
advancements in yarns
that they no longer needed the rubber
cord but no one had stopped to say do we
still need to put this so
i immediately took the rubber cord out
of it and another thing i learned was
the way that they were doing
sizing was just so blew me away they
would figure out a size by putting them
on plastic forms
and they would all put it on a plastic
form they had different size forms and
they would stand back with their
clipboards and go
yep that's a size medium
and i'd lean in and i go ask her how she
feels
so at spanx we put our product on women
my mother
my grandmother who's 90 my sister-in-law
cassie i mean all of my friends the
girls at spanx
we're testing it on real women and we
want to test it more than two seconds to
say yep that looks like a medium we we
have people wear it for a week
wash it tell us if it rolled did it move
did it stay in place how did you feel
very concerned with spanx garments and
how they made you feel
when you get a 1 000 on your s.a.t
i probably got like a 980. i've
convinced myself that i broke a thousand
creativity becomes a survival skill it's
a necessity to get into the
door to interview to sell everything
for me revolved around creativity so one
day at the recording studio
i walk in and there's a cassette sitting
on the music board
and it's the cassette that changed my
life the cassette was by an artist a rat
pioneer named dana dane
dana was a brooklyn-born artist his
first album was one of my favorite
albums and this was an advanced copy in
the late 80s that nobody
nobody had sitting there i wanted to
listen to it so i asked the engineer if
i could borrow the cassette
and i would bring the cassette back
after i listened to it he said sure
a couple of days later i'm on my way to
los angeles to visit a friend
i'm listening to it in my sony walkman
if anyone remembers those
sony walkman yeah and when i'm on the
plane i read that the owner of delicious
finals favorite
artist this is a big label tone lok and
young his favorite artist
is dana dane so when i land in
california
i cold called delicious vinyl i get all
the way up to the assistant of this guy
she has no idea what i'm talking about
i'm talking very fast like a new yorker
i have dana's tape i know mike's a fan
of she puts me on hold
she comes back two minutes later and she
says dana if you can be here at two
o'clock
mike ross would love to meet you dana
will be there two o'clock
two o'clock comes that dana's a
brooklyn-born guy like i said
african-american goldtooth
not me i pushed the now a good friend of
mine though
push the button they said i said hey i'm
dana here from micros oh
mike is expecting you dana come right in
i walk in they escort me into the
office loke's record young's record he's
got this funky candle going they sit me
down
i'm sitting there i'm waiting no idea
what's going to happen
in walks mike ross and says to me not as
politely
who in the world are you there's a
famous quote by harry truman
if you can't convince them confuse them
it works so far so i start saying oh i
work at the same studio as dana i know
you're a fan of dana he must be late
he has an advanced tape can i put in my
cassette that i did at dana studio
you have a cassette what do you do i
wrap
huh put it in put in my cassette
and he says the four words that every
artist struggling artist wants to hear
who's your lawyer i don't have a lawyer
i have a dad so i give him my dad's
number my dad owns a plumbing my dad
owns a plumbing supply house
in mineola i call my father when we
leave i said dad i think i just got a
record deal if someone calls you
we got our foot in the door we're gonna
figure the rest out later
get all the documents that started a
journey
of getting my foot in the door and
figuring it out
later a key thing in creativity starting
the process
trusting the process and letting it
evolve because if you don't get your
foot in the door if you don't start
nothing happens i did it with a company
called marquee jet we sold it to warren
buffett i did it with our company's eco
coconut water we sold it to coca-cola
on an individual level i think it is
always uh it's always really good if
if there's something that you're
incredibly passionate about
and um and just sort of are fine to be
intrinsically interesting
and and that that people pursue that um
and so the you know one of the one of
the the resolutions i came up
with a number of years ago was to always
uh um value substance over status
substance over prestige um and
you know if i sort of it was giving my
younger self advice on what to
what to do or how to how to think about
um
your when's one's life i you know i
probably
i think i you know um i probably would
still go to stanford
um you know i i might still go to law
school
um but i'd ask i'd ask sort of i'd ask a
lot more questions
why why i was doing these things and i
think uh
i think if i was honest about it too
much of it was driven by
um by prestige and status and not
quite enough about um really the
substance of uh
of trying to learn things and you know i
had sort of this i sort of think of it
as this
sort of crazy rolling quarter life
crisis and sort of
culminated in this uh in this you know
big new york law firm where
you know from the outside everybody
wanted to get in from the inside
everybody wanted to get out
um you know um after i lasted seven
months and three days and after uh
um and uh when i when i when i left one
of the people
down the hall said you know it's so
reassuring to see you leave peter i had
no idea it was possible to escape from
alcatraz
which which again uh and you know and
again i
and all you had to do was go through the
front door but our identity
um people's identities get so wrapped up
and
the things they compete for that it was
inconceivable for people
to actually do that and and then the
question was you know well how had i
ended up there
why had i not thought about that more
and i think it was
um that i had taken too many of these
shortcuts of valuing
sort of what was prestigious what was
conventional over
what i uh what i really wanted to do so
i think i think always
substance over status what do you think
it'll take for you to get over
insecurity moving forward
i'm not trying you're not trying i'm not
trying to i thought you said if you
could get rid of it you'd be able to do
bigger
unbelievable but but it's not it's not
it's not a target i have
letting go of insecurity no i think it's
just a human condition i think it's part
of the game i think it's part of
being a human being any more than i want
to get rid of my arms you know
or my legs or my arms and my legs my
body my body is a limitation
yeah you know so um how do you manage it
better than like
for people that are saying i you know i
want a 10x but i always have insecurity
and fear that i'm going to fail and
people are going to show up and
yeah the deal is going to i'm going to
go broke how do you personally
get a conversation to yourself to the
insecurity and fear
yeah it's not stop it's come
you know for me for me fear fear the
things i i'm scared of i'm like
come on you know they it's calling me
says hey come play over here
it's an indicator it's a good indicator
not a bad indicator lean into it
lean into it come play with me okay so i
either have fear because it's really
dangerous
and stupid or like physically dangerous
yeah let me get to the edge of this
thing i'm gonna get on the other side of
that thing i'm probably gonna be scared
yeah
now why am i gonna be scared though like
because i don't know what it feels like
to fall you know this many floors and
hit
yeah maybe it does maybe there's no big
deal about maybe dying is not even a big
deal right but i don't have the exp
i don't consciously have the experience
so you know i used to be like
i can't buy a 78 000 house i was
terrified the first house i bought
i don't know what i'm doing because
you're not experienced i don't have the
experience man yeah
this this is the problem and you're not
going to have the experience if you
don't move through the fear
and a lot of people do it once and then
they don't do it again you got
like it's not going away yeah
it's just gonna you're gonna get used to
you're gonna get used to the ski boots
you know the first time you put them on
man they're freaking banging your shins
like i can't mend but you just we're
into them we also are big believers in
in united way and and what goes on there
and that's more at a business level we
sort of think every business
ought to do that it's a basic thing
because social services
uh we think have a a deserve particular
priority
in terms of drawing employees in to
to help help the community and there's
ways to take those fundraising things
within a company and have contests and
comparisons and
great stories get the word out make it
fun make it easy
you know it's just a piece of email the
easiest thing to do is click and say you
want to give your fair share and then
we send you no more email uh so we've
made it the easiest thing to do is
is uh is participate
in terms of individuals it's quite
different you know you can
take and give to groups like united way
who are really thinking about everything
in the community or you can find things
and
most people mix this you can find things
that you're particularly interested in
that you know about that a relative
benefited from or that you want to go
and volunteer
in uh you know microsoft does the thing
now for every hour
that somebody volunteers we actually uh
make a grant to that organization
because
that says that there they care about it
and they think it's
it's doing very good work now for
individuals at some levels
probably most you're giving is going to
be in the community where you know
what's going on
i'm a big believer that that the some of
the greatest inequities are on a global
basis
and so one of the things our foundation
tries to get out is the names of a
number of organizations like
save the children or global fund or
vaccine fund that we know
are taking dollars in a very efficient
way
and saving lives and improving
conditions and you know i would hope
that as people are able to be fairly
generous that this international
component that it be part
of of what they're doing in the
beginning nobody wanted a tesla
i can tell you that uh
the the the when we made the original
sort of roads to the sports car
uh people were like why would i want an
electric car that's
my gasoline car works fine
i'm like no electric car is better i
should try it um
and it was you know hard to get people
to
do a test drive first of all nobody knew
who we were
and then we heard this company and like
yeah we're named after nikola tesla you
know that guy nope
um so
for sure we were doing push in the
beginning because people said
there was no one telling us that they
wanted an electric car so it was not it
was not out of like
you know it was like lots of people
coming up to me saying hey i really want
an electric car
i heard that zero times um
some people like it's like man we're
gonna make an electric car and show that
these things can be good
um and then people want them um
you know it's like it's like henry ford
said that like the
you know we're talking about the model t
it's like if you ask the public
what they wanted they'd say a faster
horse
so if you did like a big survey and say
well hey public
before automobiles what would you like
it's like well i'd like my horse to go
three miles an hour faster
and eat less food and uh
you know be stronger and live longer and
that kind of thing
um there will be basically a bunch of
incremental improvements on horse
um because people when you say like what
about an
automobile that car that drives itself
like what are you talking about that's
that sounds crazy um but when you
actually make an
automobile and give it to people and say
okay now this is a horse where you can
keep it in the barn
and if you leave for a month it's still
alive
yeah so carry
more more weight than a horse and go
further and that kind of thing
so yeah the it's like
when when it's a radically new product
people don't know that they want it
because
it's just not in their in their scope i
think
when they first started making tvs
they did a nationwide survey i think
this might have been like
46 or 48 it's like famous nationwide
survey
will you ever buy a tv now i was like 96
percent of respondents said no
someone some crazy number like basically
everyone's like would you buy a tv
and maybe they put a price in there or
something i don't know but it was
famously almost everyone said they would
not buy tv
but they didn't know what they're
talking about so the big game changing
stuff at the beginning is a company push
kind of a thing most of the time but
then
changes to the product over time can be
a lot more customer pull kind of a focus
yeah changes the product over time can
be
incremental changes um then
the customers can certainly tell you
it's good to get customer feedback to
say
how can we improve the product um
and once they're using it they can say
okay i like this thing about it i don't
like this other thing and then we can
improve the product over
time customer feedback after they they
have
the fundamental thing is is great if
we've given the world a voice
look at what's happened in the last year
you've had elections in the last years
elections manipulated hate speech that's
gone viral and turned offline
it certainly seems like this mission has
been accomplished in many ways and and
there's a whole new set of problems that
perhaps
you guys didn't foresee and now we're in
a very
complicated place where there's not an
easy solution
yeah there's these are complex issues
that you can't fix
you manage them on an ongoing basis but
look do you think that the world is
better with everyone having a voice and
having the ability to express their
opinion
um and being able to connect to who they
want i don't think we're going back to a
world where
there were just a handful of gatekeepers
who got to control what ideas get
expressed
and even if we could well i'm trying to
make it so we're not i mean that's why
making it so that we're building these
independent governance mechanisms and
things like that are really important
and that's that's work that i
that i really care about um but i think
that the world will keep on moving in
this direction
people will more people will keep on
getting a voice uh
i think that that's good and and and i
think
there are certainly going to be issues
that we need to work through over time
but i think that while we are doing that
we can't lose sight of all of the
really positive things that are that are
happening here as well
not just in terms of communities and
people being able to to connect with
with groups that are really meaningful
to them whether it's around a disease
or or a community around veterans that
they wouldn't be able to connect to
otherwise
but even if you just think about the
economic impact of what we're doing
you know we serve 80 million small
businesses around the world
about half of them have told us that
they're hiring people
because of using our tools and that
without facebook and the tools that we
that we provide um that they that their
business would be significantly smaller
and they wouldn't be hiring as many
people as they are
so you know a study came out the us
economy added about four and a half
million jobs over the last year
if you just look at like what people are
telling us the small businesses who use
our tools
we've directly been able to contribute
to creating many more jobs than that
across the world
so i think that this is the power of
giving people a voice
giving small businesses giving
communities giving everyone everywhere
the ability to connect with the people
who who they care about and get their
opinion across
and giving everyday people the power
that previously only big companies would
have had
so that's it the world is going to go
more in that direction
and i think by and large that's a good
thing so i'm really proud of the work
that we're doing on this and
we there are big issues and i'm not
trying to to say that there aren't that
we need to work through
but i i do think that sometimes you can
you can get the flavor
from a lot of this from from some of the
coverage that
um that's all there is and um and i
don't think that that's right either we
need to make sure that we address these
these questions these are really big and
important things for the future of our
society and the future of the internet
but we also need to keep pushing in the
direction of empowering more people when
god created this planet
he created of several species now if
you're an atheist it's okay
call it the force let me just say god
for now so i don't have to say the god
the forest god the forest let's just say
god right now
god creates a planet earth and first of
all he creates
which a lot of people in different
organizations want
a perfect social economic world where
everything is free
don't worry about a thing you're taken
care of there's no extra imagination
necessary
it's all gonna be given to you so he
creates the oyster he says oyster
i'm giving you a free house to live in
i'm calling it a shell
i'm gonna put at the bottom of the ocean
to protect you from your enemies
you have food clothing all the food you
want
protection everything you want the
perfectly taken care of while you're in
your measly little life as an oyster
but you're not going to go anywhere you
stay there at the bottom of the ocean
but you totally got your free food free
clothing free everything you want
then god created something called the
eagle eagle whole different species
eagle you want a house you go out and
build it take the top of a mountain take
the top of a tree
go out and build your own house you want
some food to eat
no problem go out there and find it
eagle
and the eagle flies through miles in the
wintertime of
rain sleet snow and wind just to feed
its young
did you know the eagle fails 95
of the time a total failure it's so big
and cumbersome that when it comes upon
its prey
they're wild they shoot off in a
different direction and it misses
five percent of the time it succeeds and
what does it succeed to do
it succeeded to be the strongest bird in
the sky
the only one that we know of anywhere in
the world that could fly into
the thermals of a hurricane and ride
them to have fun
now the eagle unlike the oyster can go
anywhere
it wants anywhere it wants yeah gambles
it does this on its own but it goes
wherever
it wants now that eagle and not the
oyster
is the emblem of america and also on the
flag of many many
countries as a general matters of one
piece of specific finance
financial advice i would say you know
avoid credit cards just forget about
them
uh we're in various businesses that
issue credit cards the american public
loves credit cards but if you start
revolving debt on credit cards you're
going to be paying
18 or 20 percent and you can't make
progress in your financial life going
around borrowing money at 18 or 20
percent you can make a lot of money by
lending it out at
18 or 20 over time you know if you can
find anybody that's good
that will borrow from you but you don't
want to be on the side of the equation
that's always behind in life uh
you know i was lucky i'd saved about ten
thousand dollars by the time i got out
of school that ten thousand dollars was
really worth millions i might have
earned later on because after you get a
family and everything the
expenses roll in but but those were my
tools to work with but it was only
because i was ahead of the game
if you're behind the game by ten
thousand dollars at some point and
paying eighteen or twenty percent
interest on it you will never you know
you'll never get out of it
so the trick i've got a partner that
says
all i want to know is where i'm going to
die so i'll never go there you know and
uh and that's true in financial matters
as well you want to figure out where you
don't want to be
ahead of time and avoid that and i get
about a dozen letters a day
from people who are having terrible
problems and there are two reasons why
they have terrible problems
one is a number of them have had health
problems of some sort i mean they have
really been hit by some or somebody in
their family has been hit by some kind
of catastrophic
illness and that is it you know it's a
terrible thing to happen to any family
and they get in they run up bills they
can't pay and and
really only society can solve that one
uh
uh in terms of protecting people against
that that's just plain bad luck
but the other one is from people who run
up credit card debt
and uh they're facing bankruptcy or
they've been through bankruptcy once
before
and they owe a whole bunch of money and
they can't they can't even pay the
interest let alone pay any principal
and half of my letters come from people
like that and that that that problem is
avoidable
catastrophic illness is not but but uh
credit card debt is something you bring
on yourself and
it's way better it's way easier to stay
out of trouble
than to get out of trouble financially
and and uh i will guarantee you if you
run a big credit card that you will be
in trouble
uh probably the rest of your life in
terms of
uh your financial situation on the other
hand if you get ahead of the game
uh even it's on a very modest scale
so that money is coming in from
investing
and you're you're people owe you money
or
equities owe you ownership uh you'll be
way ahead of the game
compared to paying it being always being
paying
your creditors every month so my advice
to you is
if you can't pay for it don't buy it the
future has no
experts
right we entrepreneurs
someday we are the experts
right so this is what i think and
when you
when you entrepreneur get used to
failure today say alibaba you
succeed well our company won't last 102
years
why 102 years because every
target every goal we give to our team
should be very accurate
we were born in 1999 last century we had
one year we want to spend 100 years and
plus one year one or two across three
centuries
so very accurate we never see we are
successful because we are only
19 years old there is 83 years to go
so we will never see we are successful
we just survived
19 years we are lucky but
in the past 19 years we have made
thousands of mistakes
as entrepreneurs don't learn from other
people how they succeed
learn from how these people fail
because a lot of mba schools they teach
you success
successful case studies when you read
too many successful you think you can be
successful no
there are a lot of things that you don't
know
because you know some business school
came to
alibaba write case studies they say i
know this is
alibaba and i said no this is not
alibaba they wanted me to sign
after one week study they say this is
case study alibaba ace no this is not me
they say jack you don't know you
and that's all right i signed and next
to five years
every year there is a case study in
qinghua university i was
invited sitting at the back listening to
the mba schools talk
learning about our case study and they
always put a competitor
competitor and alibaba who will succeed
for five years
all they always agree alibaba will die
the competitor will win but five years
all the competitors died
so how can you learn from the case study
like that
learn from the mistakes because the
mistake most of the companies i
i talked to entrepreneurs most of the
mistakes they
made are the same most of the success
reasons you don't know the different
reasons so
when you learn from the mistakes not
because you want to avoid the mistakes
because
when you see the mistakes when you have
this kind of problems
you know how to face it an entrepreneur
have a strong heart towards the
difficulties
mistakes the troubles the failures but
should it be a warm and soft heart to
your colleagues
and to the customers we haven't had any
existential crisises
knock on wood i find i don't want to
jinx anything
but we've had a lot of kind of
dramatic events i remember um
early on we only had 125
employees when barnes and noble who the
big
united states bookseller opened their
online website to compete against us
barnesandnoble.com we'd had about a
two-year
window we opened in 95 they opened in 97
and at that time all of the headlines
and the funniest were about how we were
about to be
destroyed by this much larger company we
had 125 employees
and 60 million dollars a year in annual
sales
60 million with an m and that
and barnes noble at the time had 30 000
employees
and about three billion dollars in sales
so they were giant we were tiny
and we had limited resources and the the
headlines were
um very negative about amazon and the
one that's most minimal or
memorable was just amazon.toast
and um and so i called an all hands
meeting
which was not hard to do with just 125
people
we got in a room and because it was so
um scary
for all of us this idea that now we
finally had a big competitor
that literally everybody's parents were
calling and saying you know are you okay
it's usually the moms calling and asking
their children are you gonna be okay
so and i said look you know it it's okay
to be afraid
um but don't be afraid of our
competitors because they're never gonna
send us any money
be afraid of our customers and if we
just stay focused on them
in in in in instead of obsessing over
this big competitor that we just got
that we'll be fine um and i really do
believe that i think that if you stay
focused then the more
uh drama there is and everything else no
matter what the drama is whatever the
external distraction is
the the what your response to it should
be to
double down on the customer satisfying
them not just satisfying them delighting
them
when i was a kid glenn i was like
i knew i was gonna do something great
and had zero reason to believe that
right like it was a total fantasy
or maybe not i think everybody has that
i would imagine that every kid
um has this idea that they're they're
they're meant for greatness
i know i did i always thought i was
gonna be something great i remember my
twin brother
uh he he would he'd be in the mirror man
he's like eight years old we're eight
years old he's singing
in the mirror like he's a rock star
right i had to listen to that
all the time and and then i start
thinking
man man if he's going to be a rock star
he's going to go on to be a big rock
star
and and and i can't you know because i
that that that wasn't my deal
i said what am i going to be and then i
thought i'm going to be a baseball
player
i actually believed i was going to be a
baseball player
right dude i wasn't fast enough i wasn't
strong enough
i didn't have the arm i mean i had no
talent
i didn't have the work ethic you know i
didn't have somebody pushing me so
i've just always underestimated what i
could do i think everybody does that
that's why this 10x thing that's why i
keep telling people man
you're thinking too small when i talk to
people about real estate
don't do two units
gotta start somewhere no you don't have
to start with two units
you could actually start with 32 right
and and by the way it's going to be a
lot easier to make money on 32 than it
is too
sure if if you could just believe that
you can
you know and right now it's a time where
people are going to have to start
believing they can do something else
because we're going to move into a
period of time now where there's going
to be massive
transition enforced transition on
everyone one part that i'm
always um very focused on is sort of
the structure of these companies and how
how well
are people aligned and so you can um
and uh making sure that people are you
know aligned properly not just that they
say i think this is sort of a very a
very legal kind of a
framework to think about what are
people's incentives you know are they
going to be aligned or not and i think
you want to both have formal alignment
where you set the structure right and
you want to have informal alignment
where
the people would naturally try to work
together well in one
one way or another um and i think that
somehow
tends to get obscured in all these other
ways um you know there's always a
there's always a uh there's always a
prehistory question i like to ask
founders of of companies which is
um how did you how did you
meet what's the prehistory of the
company before you got started
i find that to be really instructive a
set of questions to ask
a bad answer is something like you know
we met
a week ago at a social networking
function
at a business networking function we
decided to start a company because we
both wanted to be entrepreneurs
um you know that's like saying i married
the first person i met at the slot
machines in las vegas
and you might hit the jackpot but it's
probably a really bad idea
um and a much better answer is you know
we've been talking about this for a long
time
you know maybe one of us is more on the
tech side the other one's more on the
business side we have these sort of
complementary skills
and uh and so i think this question of
um
alignment and structure is um is
incredibly important
sometimes it's like god has other plans
it's like something hits you and you
don't even know
and well frankly the things going
through my mind were
what's you know what's what's going on
what's wrong with me
uh uh i would try i would spend my
makeup trying to cover it up because
rosacea's bright red and you get these
um
patches on your skin and they're
textured like sandpaper rash right
almost
yes and it's very textured and so um
no i mean i think any time you know
something happens to us whether it's
a physical thing a physical change an
emotional
situation um something with our health
right any time we have something like
that
you know the the it's hard to go through
the
the beginning of it because i struggled
a little bit honestly i had thoughts
like okay
am i pretty anymore like just those
things like i'm embarrassed i never even
said that out loud by the way but like
that's the truth i just
started doubting myself i started um
doubting okay is this gonna affect my
career
you know but in in the midst of the the
start of kind of that
that i guess struggle of going okay my
physical appearance is changing
let me wrap my head around this um uh
is when i started really looking into
makeup and and trying everything out
there spending my tiny paycheck on
on uh every product i could get my hands
on from the most expensive to least
expensive and
and uh there's that famous saying like
you know sometimes we make our mess our
message and
that's sort of what happened it was this
entrepreneurial moment where
i realized there's nothing out there
that works for me right nothing that
will solve my problem
and there must be so many other people
that have just given up on makeup
because it doesn't work for them and
it's like okay nothing worked
i went to dallas after college because a
bunch of my buddies were down there
and i got a job working as a bartender
at night and was looking for a job
during the day and got a job working for
a retail software company
and this was in the early days of pcs
and was doing okay there
and then about nine months in i made um
let me add
i was living six guys in a three bedroom
apartment
and i was sleeping on the floor it was
the rattiest nastiest [ __ ] you've
ever seen in your life
i mean and i literally didn't have a
closet didn't have a drawer
all my [ __ ] was in a pile on the floor i
had my one towel that i stole from motel
6 that had a hole in it
that was mine um and so
i was trying to grind it out and learn
tech which i really
realized that i loved and i made the one
day i called up my boss a guy named
michael humecki
h-u-m-e-c-k-i and i said michael i've
got this deal i'm going to close now
it's 1500
commission to me which meant i can move
out of the and
and so i said one of my responsibilities
was to open up the retail store
you know make sure the door was open the
floors were clean and all that kind of
stuff i said look
i've got this big deal i want to close
it and he said no you need to be at the
store i'm like
i got someone to watch goes no you need
to be at the store so i made the
executive decision that
if i went and picked up a fifteen
thousand dollar check for this company
um your business software he would see
the light and all would be good
and i'd have my fifteen hundred dollar
commission fired my ass
um seriously michael hugh mckee and
i'm not going to hold it assuming you've
spoken to him since then one time one
time literally after broadcast.com went
public
he sent me a letter asking if i would
invest in his company
you should bring him on shark tank
anyway so that was the only time i
talked to michael humecki
and so and so he fired me
and so there i was still in the [ __ ]
hole with my one
motel six towel um and no bedrooms
and so it was then that we started micro
solutions and i had no money
and so i went to this company called
architectural lighting and i said look i
got nothing but i know you were trying
you want this time in billing software
if you front me the 500
i'm going to start this company and i
promise you that i'll make it work and
if i can't make it work
i'll walk your dog i'll wash you know
your car i'll do whatever to make it up
to you
just trust me and give me the shot they
did i took that 500
bought the spent 250 on the software got
that to work really fast
and then asked for referrals and built
this company that
then went on to become one of the first
companies that did local area network
this was the early 80s
and then went wide area networks and as
you said we sold it to compuserve
and along the way i kept on reinvesting
and
one day i went to the atm and i had all
zeros
you know which which was not fun but
like you said we we ended up building it
we had
36 million dollar revenue run rate and
sold it to compuserve which was part of
h
r block and you know all was in
alignment again and
it wasn't like i started it thinking
okay if i fail i don't care
it was purely out of necessity i didn't
know what else to do i always
was dancing to my own drum my parents
gave me a really long leash which is a
great gift
for me growing up they let me do
whatever i wanted to do
within reason yeah and i always you know
all of us we always come against this
wall of fear you know this crazy wall of
fear
and you can either go to the wall and
turn around you can go through the
wall yes and i was i always every time i
went around
turned around and went back home because
i was too scared i had crazy resentment
or crazy guilt that i wasn't able to do
it regret not resentment
yeah regret yeah and every time i went
through the wall
and got to the other side it was so
addicting and i was so proud of myself
so uh let me just give you a quick
example when i was growing up
i grew up in new york city uh on long
island
in the 80s when break dancing and rap
and all this stuff was happening yep and
i was really into breakdancing i don't
know i don't look like it
but you know get some cardboard out here
man we need to do something might get
some cardboard okay
and i decided that like i could make
more money
probably if i went to washington dc you
know because the kids in washington dc
couldn't be as good as the kids in new
york we invented this whole
genre so i got my friend myron who's my
partner my sister just got her driver's
license
and i convinced her to drive us to
washington dc and the whole drive down
i was having all that self-doubt yeah
you know at a young age
14 15 years old like what if the kids
are better what if no one shows up what
if we get booed what if you know what if
we go there and
i stink yeah and so i was almost talking
myself out i was building the wall of
doubt
up brick by brick in my own head yeah
and when we got there
we went to a little bank in uh
georgetown and we set up a boom box in a
parking lot of a bank
and we hit play and my friend started
spinning on his head and he passed it to
me and the crowd gathered around
and ultimately after i did my thing more
people came i took my hat and i passed
it around we made about
200 i paid my sister for the gas money
and then
myron and i split 82 41
each and this guy you know he's counting
up the money and he's counting up the
money and he gets all the money and then
he sprints over to me and he gives me a
bear hug and he goes jess
rich and
what the reason why we were rich is
because on that particular trip
despite all the fear this young little
kid that was so scared
i went around that wall and i realized i
could be rewarded
and i was like i want more of that how
did you get through
like tactically to a sale in the
encyclopedia world like people don't
want to hear from you
so like how do you overcome that that's
what a question asked me
the average encyclopedia salesman
lasted three days i was out for three
and a half years
and the way it worked in those days it
was commission only so the way it worked
is you went for an interview
they told you all you could possibly
make off commission only
and we were in training for three days
it was a presentation that was scripted
we'd have to memorize the whole thing
well when you got in the field you
remember
parts of it you knock on doors you're
not quite sure of yourself a lot of
dirts are close in your face
but what happens after a while you start
getting used to it and you see
what you can say or do that'll make it
better
but when you go back the next day with
your other sales people what you see
what you do what did i say
uh so let's say knock on 100 door skin
into one give
10 presentations to sell one book but
then when you get better and better at
it
through your experiences and losses
along the way it sharpens you up
where all of a sudden i got to a point
where if i gave three presentations i
have no less than one order
commission only but i believe that i
could do that i believe that
colleges were the best set of books
because a high school student could read
it it wasn't like a college manual you
had to read
and i was doing something good for
somebody so you have to believe
that what you're doing is good is going
to benefit somebody and you learn
as you go okay do i look someone in the
eye see a lot of people don't know these
things look someone in the eye
all too often people say it's hard to
look someone in the eye
because you feel uncomfortable of course
you do they're not on the same
wavelength you're on or the same
frequency so what do you do how do you
overcome that
you learn these things along the way you
look them right between the eyes or
their eyebrows looks like you're looking
over the eye
i've been working on a book for a couple
of years with some of these tips and
it's not ready yet maybe next year it'll
be ready but uh there's all these things
and of course smile
smile's the most wonderful thing god
gave us and you don't smile when you
first talk to somebody
you smile before you knock on their door
and if your day
sucks you fake it hi how you doing so
when you smile
everything changes people change
everybody works hard
and everybody has their own dreams there
is
there was a time where i used to spend a
lot of energy wanting things
wanting things of course it's easy for
me to say oh things don't define you
because i got a lot of things things
nice i like them but this is what i
learned
when you can surrender to the dream
you get to live in the space of the
higher power
you get to live in the space that you
purposefully have come to earth to claim
for yourself
so around 1984
i was sitting in bed one morning sunday
morning
should have been in church but i
wouldn't
i was reading the new york times review
of the color purple and i thought whoa
this sounds like a really great book
i got out of bed in my pajamas put on my
galoshes
and went to the store to get the copy of
the color purple
i read the color purple in one afternoon
got
went back to the bookstore bought every
book of the color purple
i took the books to the office and i
said to everybody y'all got to read this
book oh my god you got to read this book
color purple i needed a book club i
didn't have one
so i passed out the book to everybody i
knew please read the color purple read
the color purple
then i start to hear that somebody's
going to do a movie about the color
purple
but i don't know anybody in the movie
business by this time i was on am
chicago
i don't know anybody i start praying to
god god please help me find a way to get
into color purple
i say jesus i don't even have to have a
speaking part
i will be because i went to the movies
and i saw on the movie credits
at the last credit there's something
called best boy
so i said jesus if you just let me be
best girl
that'll be all right by me i can be best
girl
i can carry the script i can help the
people with the water i can do whatever
so i start praying for the color purple
as as divine law would have it
quincy jones comes to chicago
and he is in chicago for one
half of a day because somebody has filed
a suit against michael jackson
claiming that billie jean was their
lover and that's not his song
so quincy had taken the red eye to
chicago
he was in his hotel room he was coming
out of the shower and the television
in his hotel room is on am chicago
there sits little chubby me
with my jerry curl
on am chicago quincy jones
tells ruben cannon the casting agent i
think i found
sophia so i get a call for moving canon
who says i'm calling about a movie
it's called moon song would you be
interested to come and audition and i
say i have not been praying for moon
song
[Applause]
[Music]
i had not been playing for moon song
i've been praying for the color purple
he said well i think you should come and
and audition so i go to audition
you know movie people they make
everything all secret steven spielberg
didn't want anybody know he was doing
color purple so
on the outside of the script it says
moon song but i know
all the words by heart
so when i open the script i know this is
the color purple jesus
this is the color purple
yes
so i auditioned for the color purple i
can't even believe it they don't just
want me to be the water girl
or the best girl they are asking me do i
want a part in the movie
oh that i'm thinking prayer prayer works
prayer works but listen to this
three months pass three months is a long
time
i auditioned in february march april
may comes i haven't heard anything so i
call reuben cannon
i say mr cannon i'm sorry sir i haven't
heard anything i expected to hear
something by now and reuben cannon
african-american man says to me
you don't call me
i call you and i didn't call you
do you understand that i have real
actresses who have auditioned for this
part
real actresses and he tells me who just
left his office and i went well okay i'm
not getting that part
so i hang up the phone and i start
crying
i can't believe that god has played this
trick on me i think
this is a trick so i decide that this is
because
the fat has finally caught up with me
the fat has finally caught up with me
and now i must get rid of the fat
in two weeks
[Applause]
i am going to go to a fat farm
and i'm going to lose 25 pounds
i'm gonna drink a lot of green juice
i'm gonna have some cleanses and
colonics
so i i i also
was trying to make peace with it i said
god i don't understand i thought it was
for me you ever had that talk with god
i i thought it was for me i thought it
was for me
god you let me audition with somebody
named harpo
that's my name backwards jesus that was
a sign wasn't it a sign
and then three months pass and then then
reuben cannon says
real actresses have just left his office
so i start to pray on the track i'm out
on the track
at the fat farm
and i am running around at the track at
the fat farm
it starts to rain y'all know how that is
but i don't even care because i am
praying to god
to help me to let it go
help me let it go because now i've
become obsessed with it and it's now
controlling my life
i start praying running around the track
[Music]
and i keep hearing this noise and i
i can't there's nobody on the track but
me and i'm running around the track
and i look around and it is my thighs
rubbing together
[Applause]
it's my thighs
[Applause]
my thighs are rubbing together
causing this thunderous sound
[Applause]
there's nobody on the track so then i
really start to cry
oh lord help me help me let it go
help me let it go help me let it go god
help me let it go and you ever did this
prayer where you say okay lord i'll come
and let it go then you get up and you go
well i think i still got a little bit of
it
i did help me let it go but i am not
going to be able to see the other
actress
in my part i won't be able to see it
won't be able to see color purple
just can't never see it the rest of my
life i won't be able to see it
so then i started i don't know where it
came from
i surrender all
i surrender all
all to thee my
blessed savior
i surrender
all i sang and i cried i
sang and i cried and i prayed some more
until
i could reach the point where not only
not only will i be able to go to the
movie but i can bless
the other actress i can bless her
i can say i bless you
i bless you i bless you with this i
surrender all i
surrender all
all to thee
my blessed savior
i surrender all
and i tell you in my greatest
testimony
that the instant i laid that thing down
[Applause]
i'm telling you when i laid it down
when i laid it down and it didn't have
me
anymore it had no control over me
anymore
i didn't feel anything about it anymore
when i let it go
when i intentionally surrendered it to
the power
that was greater than i could ever know
the instant that happened a woman comes
running
out of the cafeteria
screaming aufry
is your name all free
for 10 years nobody could pronounce my
name
i said yes she said somebody's on the
telephone for you he's a named spielberg
i get to the phone
he says i hear you're at a fat farm
[Applause]
i said no sir
this is a health retreat
[Applause]
he says i'd like to see you in my office
in california tomorrow this was in
wisconsin i was i'd like to see you in
my office
and if you lose a pound you could lose
this part
no problem do i have
i'll have no problem not losing a pound
so honey i packed my bags
and i stopped at the dairy queen
i got three scoops just in case i'd lost
a half a pound
[Applause]
and the next day i was in steven
spielberg's office and he said
you're hired you're hired
[Music]
if you want seven more amazing lessons
from billionaires check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there you should just
be yourself
right i mean i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give what anybody thought
or said
i was just going to be myself i find if
i don't get enough sleep then i'm quite
grumpy